et dans ce contexte d'évacuation massive
de femmes d'enfants et de personnes
âgées la mobilisation générale a été
décrétée hier matin par les autorités
locales du donbass les hommes âgés de 18
à 55 ans ont eu interdiction de sortir
du territoire en vue de leur enrôlement
dans l'armée notre envoyé spécial à
donetsk et antoine gayraud est allé à
leur rencontre
à la suite de l'appel à la mobilisation
générale lancé par le dirigeant de cette
république autoproclamée de deux nièces
qu plusieurs bureaux de recrutement ont
été mises en place un petit peu partout
dans la ville au revoir l'un d'entre eux
vous avez reçu l'ordre de convocation ou
vous êtes volontaire volontaire qu'est
ce qui vous a incité à devenir
qu'attendez vous ce sera nécessaire un
jour le plus tôt serait le mieux seul
comme on dit il faut faire résistance
au moment nous serons tous obligés de
venir car hormis mille personne ne
pourra me répond
défendre notre maison je n'ai aucune
autre pensée aucune autre émotion
je te montre ça se passe ici depuis 2014
on en a marre franchement il faut en
finir avec ça tous ces hommes sont venus
s'engager avec une seule idée un seul
objectif en tête qu'enfin se termine les
hostilités entre résignation et
détermination